they season four finale what was your
reaction to the show and did you feel
about fans reaction to the show
you know I I don't want anybody to get
too scared like in the fact that
everyone or most of us kind of disband
it a little bit and kind of walked away
from Star City just for a little bit but
you know we just needed a little
vacation I needed to go to maybe quarter
Maltese or Hawaii or somewhere with a
beach and I feel like Diggle and Lyla
needed to do the same thing and it's
kind of like relax and feel like we're
all gonna be coming back at our own pace
for our own reasons so I don't want
anyone to be too afraid I'm actually two
episodes behind so she just spoiled it
from that's what I do it's okay I'll get
over it
okay just a question yeah hello we heard
the major spoiler about a new villain
that's coming for the new season that's
something I don't know about really
please tell me it isn't but we heard
somebody called James he's supposed to
come and he's not supposed to have any
superpower can you confirm that this is
rumor actually I don't ever get told any
information so I this is the first I'm
hearing of it so I cannot confirm or
deny it for you but I wouldn't be
surprised if there was another villain
off the bat right guys I mean I need a
reason to keep going if it's a rumor
it's totally true yeah pretty much if it
did you feel about how your characters
progressed over the seasons
oh it's been amazing one of the my
favorite things about this show is being
able to represent not only just females
in a hole but then the way that out all
the female characters deal with just
like so badass and I really have enjoyed
being bringing you know a young girl
who's damaged and a little crazy and
full of herself in the beginning to a
real stand-up human being and taking up
evolution and having her go through
things from you know the negative part
and all that to actually losing her
family and just going through all these
real-life scenarios and growing up on
her own right and taking the time that
we did to do it was really great because
we were able to do justice to a growth
rather than just like in one year she
goes through everything and is at the
end of it she's in a speedy costume like
it was really nice to have this like
story to progress along with and I feel
like it actually groped you made me grow
up a little bit I mean not by my outfit
clearly but I think we're really
fortunate on the show to be a part of a
writing staff and production team that
values its female characters and female
cast mates so much we get to tell we get
to fight for freedom and for love and
for justice right along next to the men
sometimes we fight for our men and
sometimes we fight for our own
storylines and I think that's very rare
for females on television in general so
it's wonderful watching a character like
the turn into speedy or someone like
Nyssa who learns how to love through
Lance sisters and watching the land
sisters go through their entire
development I think we are if we have
such a wonderful cast strong females and
I think that's so important and vital
especially for the young generation
coming out very probably uh sort of a
gay relationship with Sarah wants good
stuff do you think I was a big step I
think that's a big thing for me little
TV I think it was a wonderful step and I
I appreciate the arrow riders so much
for how they dealt with it um a lot of
times if you have a character that is
not unfortunate like a male white
characters my white character there's
always an explanation for why they're
black and on the show why they're Latino
and on the show why they're Asian but
they have to have a story of some sort
to explain that or if they're gay or
lesbian or transsexual there has to be
an explanation as to why and the
beautiful thing that the writers did on
this show was they just introduced our
relationship said this is what it is we
don't have a backstory for it and
everybody just kind of accepted it and
that I love that so they weren't gay or
bi because this happened in their life
or this whatever they just were what
they were and I think that's so
important I think that's a huge step
forward it's okay
the Lance's and course we've lost both
men away have a wheel from arrow we've
lost Sara to DC's legends of tomorrow
and according los Laura Lasswell on the
show that season with her death in what
guys what was your reaction to both of
those things both Sara going over to DC
ledges tomorrow and also Laurel dying a
season I mean I think we were all very
excited for for caity lotz them to both
having Katie names make things a little
different but um yeah for Lots it was
you know a very exciting thing because
she was getting you know to be on our
own show to kind of carve out her
character a little bit away from our
show and because you know her character
came in about what season two or
something like that so it was when
you're coming into a show a couple
seasons in it's always a little
different rather than starting it from
the beginning so it was really good for
her I think that she got a fresh start
on something else but for the whole
Katie Cassidy situation that was one of
the different most difficult things that
any of us have ever had to film I mean
not that any of the deaths have ever
been easy but you know we lost Tommy
after season one we lost Moira after
season two this was four years in and so
we were all so close at this point to
the point where it more than ever this
time it felt like losing a limb but you
know she has her black siren thing
coming out on the flash which is pretty
amazing and I know that CW and DC and a
whole love to keep you know bringing
people back and playing around with the
characters and hopping us from show to
show so I'm quite excited to see what
they're going to do with our character I
don't know where she's gonna end up but
it's great to know that she's still with
us it's not like she's young I think
that's the thing of the Hawkin showed a
show with the flash setting up pretty
obviously flashpoint as the beginning of
next season
you think that you guys will be showing
up in that or well it announces one
thing I do know one piece of information
that I do have that I can potentially
confirm as not being a rumor is the fact
that what we've always done a crossovers
with arrow and flash and then we had our
this one with with legends now this year
we're going to do a crossover of arrow
flash legends and Supergirl how I don't
know
apparently said to happen so yeah we're
we're all very excited to be popping
into each other's realms and all I gotta
say is I want to be an earth too so as
long as that happens I mean you two
seems so much better than regular earth
as an actor how do you how do you feel
about crossovers they are interesting in
the sense that like we all love each
other because I mean flashes shoots
literally next door to us ooh I can walk
over and steal from their catering if
their lunches before mine that's great
so I take advantage of that all the time
and grant and Danielle and all of them
are great close friends and legends even
though it shoots in LA I mean Vancouver
as well if their stages are a little bit
off from ours but we all still get to
like you know run into each other and
hang out in the cities so we're already
kind of like a Knick close family on our
own rights away from the show so it's
always really fun coming to each other's
and and getting to play with each other
on set but the actual building of the
crossovers and shoving it into our
seasons when we have 23 episodes and
eight days to do each of those episodes
it becomes it's a very difficult thing
because we're all of a sudden not making
one hour of television in that eight
days for somehow supposed to accomplish
double the amount with twice the amount
of people I can tell you from coming on
because I haven't been a part of the
crossovers but whenever I walk on set
after they've done across over everyone
is shattered yeah just completely
shattered but the the response that you
get from every single one of them is we
love doing the crossovers because the
fans appreciate it so much
exam that is a worth it the
honest-to-goodness response from
everybody from Stephen down to the crew
that they love doing them even though
they are just Necker by the end of it
yeah it's when we start going over our
legal hours of work and we all end up
living on set and we lose our Saturdays
and sometimes our Sundays and it becomes
a bit of a jumble but it's all in the
end
tiring ly worth it and and the jokes and
the vibes on set are always just as
positive if they are as they are
doesn't show I mean it's it's we're
playing the same character throughout it
so it's not like there's much of a
difference if you know I got to go to
earth-2 or got to do something like Katy
is just becoming a whole different
superhero it would be awesome to be able
to actually really play around with like
a totally different version if you could
invent your own is to character what
would you have them do well I keep on
saying that speed or Thea needs to be an
earth to as Artemis and or as speedy
with a yellow cave because that's just
something I need in my own personal life
I am NOT the first person on the show
with a cape I might lose it it's like my
one requirement it's the one thing I've
asked for since day one it's been four
years guys we please start a whole fan
tweeting thingy or whatever it is has to
yeah yeah okay whatever just get it
going this is we need an illegal copy
amazing with the Cape just all it
matters
Justin get the deal every day not why
you see having kepta cinematic universe
apart from the TV universe is it maybe
do not wear tights in the movie or do
keep it separate in your head as well um
it's something that we have all just
kind of we we get it we're not gonna
fight about it anymore we're not going
to bring it up anymore but it was
something that in in day one when it was
started to happen and we know we were
about season 2 when they started telling
us that we had to start basically
killing off the Suicide Squad that we
were starting to build in our own Arkham
kind of who was it that was running Lyla
was kind of just keeping them all in
prison too whatever like we were
actually trying to build that on her own
on the show and I guess once DC found
out that they were going to be doing
their own movie of it we had to ask all
of the characters before we even got to
show them which was a little
annoying at first and then when you know
Stephen found out that there's going to
be a Justice League it don't seem right
Lee so that he would be playing Green
Arrow on it as well as that grant would
be playing the flash and it just seemed
like the right normal answer and they
know once I said no you can't really
fight against them for it because they
are the people who gave us a job in the
first place so you just have to sit
there on your hands be like okay yeah
and I get it I think it's above our pay
grade
you know why whatever legal matters are
happening behind the scenes as to why
they're keeping them separate but I do
know if Stephen and grant were to be
given their parts in a movie in the
movie fears they would do it in a second
they would kill it and just be amazing I
think they could totally hold their own
in there so everybody knows that
everybody I mean it's a thing we all
know that they and it proves the fact
that it does work because Marvel does it
in their own in their like own weird
right they kind of mashed between their
they're agents of shields into the
movies and stuff so it's it's a little
upsetting to see you know it is possible
and it can be done how good it would be
and how good it would be if it was done
because you're basically given the world
two different flashes all of a sudden
and it's just yeah but again we don't
know why it's happening and we can't
right hands up in the air yeah yeah
there you go you saw um you saw the
lovely called Haynes come back this year
in the Roy how was that for you and one
of the chances we might see him on the
show again in the future do things well
he just announced two weeks ago that he
is coming back in season five which is
the greatest thing ever having him come
back in season four was amazing I wish
we got to do more stuff together I
really wish that we got to see like us
both in our costumes and hopefully we'll
see that in season five put that to the
twittered as well but yeah I mean we've
all when Colton his art kind of ended we
were all just like wait why why where
are you going
can you please come back and it was so
great that he decided to come back just
for that one stint and the fact that
he's coming back for more I hope we just
lock him in a box and keep in there
forever
I might do it in my own if they don't so
just you know if you don't see Colton
for a little while and he's not posting
on Instagram
she's fine he's in my care would you
like same deal the show next I mean I'd
love to see him back as Arsenal I'd love
to see speedy and Arsenal fighting
alongside together he'd be really
confused as to why his costume was
shredded though yeah or why it didn't
fit him anymore but uh ya know I just I
want to just be working with him as much
as possible he's my favorite human being
I love him too much
Stephen almost seems to be very active
social media wise and he's always doing
something where he's giving my pizza and
a piece of store or he's doing stuff for
charity is he is he genuinely like 38
sir Chuck he is very much that guy
Stephen had I don't know how he does it
because he makes all of us look really
bad we none of us really do this and
it's horrible to say that out loud but
the guy works more than any of us do and
he still somehow has not only the energy
but the drive to keep doing so many of
these other side projects not to mention
also raise a new daughter I mean like
there's so many things that he does yeah
he said hard working men and Holly I
don't get it like I don't understand it
how where when he sleeps and how he does
it and he never gets sick like not even
a cold yeah I've seen him sick Wednesday
for years and it was not even really
sick he just coughed like twice it was
like twice in the span of three weeks
and we're like oh god Stephen oh yeah I
was like it's all going down the whole
world he'll be Emma needs 20 fine I
could be right
Johanna seen you guys tell you've been
WWE over some event yeah you know I be
there we're gonna do a tag team I mean
really let me take down like his hope
Hogan still doing it cuz I just want to
like tackle him and take him down it's
be like you are too orange why did I
panic I just met the four horsemen so
you know maybe we could do something
where she Knight tag-team against them I
think we would I take your horses you
take two horse exactly we bribed them
down we'd wear capes for you yeah we do
they'll be okay how much do you enjoy
the fight things I'm like do is it all
done by yourself oh it's the best part I
think right if they let us all do it by
ourselves I don't think I would
physically be here today not about
speaking to any of you I'm so happy
that
stunt double is as incredible not only
as a martial artist but as a human being
like I love my stunt double melissa chen
shoutout girl you're the best
um she is is honestly incredible and I
tell her every day that she's at work
that she's the real speedy and anytime
they call us to set I'm like no I'm the
stunt double guys remember like I'm the
one that stands there says something and
she does everything for real like I'm
just there as a glorified figure and you
are the actual superhero because she can
really do all that stuff she did even
does some stuff in the guys costumes
because she's so badass and rad that
some of the guys can do the show that
she can do she's it's just like I mean
our stunt double and the stunt team all
together James Bamford is a legend he is
not only the best stunt coordinator ever
but also really create director in
season 4 episodes 407 and for 1314 um
best episodes I actually have ever
worked on um and yeah I wish that we got
to do more I'm happy that we don't
because there's great people who can
really do it doing it for us and there's
also a bunch of legal reasons on why you
know we were not allowed to be around
shards of glass because I have seen it
go through a guy's calves and it is not
a pretty sight so I'm happy that we've
got these badass people representing for
us and holding it down